[Music]
perfect hey it's me Nick Kroll
I've always Gunter in the new movie sing
this state is about to explode with
major piggy power I want to address the
rumors head on about me going method
yeah I go method you know what I mean I
get into character I get into it I'm
eating a lot more bacon
I guess that's narcissistic in some way
maybe I have my breakfast outfit which
is like a red unitard and so I showed up
for breakfast with Garth who directed it
and he was like huh after seven years of
thinking I was a pig in the Black Forest
hunting for truffles dig my little snout
and found out later it was a soccer
field when you hear my vocalizing it's
like the words are dancing
god